hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
this time we're approaching the expert
level levels which means that I'm not
gonna be able to speak properly and this
is not gonna go well for me but I'm
gonna beat this no matter what no matter
what happens I have got a conquer this
because most of these levels have about
a 10 to 5 percent clear rate and that
means that 1 out of 10 or 1 out of 20
tries you succeed so to get through 16
levels of these I have to lose only
about 5 Mario's per level and this one's
just called 2 and it's made by someone
from Japan so I'm assuming it's gonna be
hard oh thank you for that I don't know
if I was supposed to get that that's
good ok so far so not bad how am I
supposed to go down here no okay oh god
its companion spring hell so I can do
this I can get a 1-up if I do this yes
yes that's 3 1ups ok so that's already
more than I need am I supposed to go oh
no I was supposed to do it
I'm not that good it's okay it's okay
it's okay I killed I got this and so
long as I get the levels with the easy
one upset think everything's well that
one office didn't mean anything on that
try because frankly I didn't complete
lovely and I forgot that that's kind of
a requirement of my face I need to get
to the end before I lose my gun I mean
it's a little early for me to be losing
my goddamn mind so let's let's take this
no no no this is just the beginning this
is just the beginning of when I lose my
goddamn mind cuz I intentionally stayed
away from the super hard levels for my
god I'm not gonna be able to get past
that am i maybe now that I'm small and
aerodynamic I'm gonna be able to get
through to the side of it he was just so
bulbous in red that I couldn't help
ramming my body and do him oh man I'm
already three down shut up I'm not gonna
pass don't be patronizing about me I
know my limitations I know what I can do
so you shut your goddamn trap if it's
the last thing outside twirl twirl yes
next [ __ ] me ah god damn it
so I need to go down oh yes okay jumps
difficult okay any of these have
anything for me a mush damn it OOP okay
so maybe I can go back get a mush cuz I
remember there was a bunch of monsters
down there okay so I just got to get a
mush
I gotta keep my mush which I had
[ __ ] you god damn there's not a problem
I just gotta get the mush through here
okay I'll take I'll take I'll take it
I'll take it I don't know how I did that
but I'll take it
okay so I gotta get over here and down
here is the spring you do these I'll
just take them off
I like the points perfect perfect
exactly what I was supposed to be able
to do there I know what I need to do now
at least for this part of the stage I
have no idea what's coming at the end of
the stage or why it's taking me so long
to get through this because frankly it's
not a [ __ ] this time no jokes no joking
around I know what I need to do and I'm
gonna do it efficiently I don't even
need the mush okay so I just got to take
this calmly enough collectedly enough
yes okay so nice spring jump on these I
thought wait what wait I thought you
could there's something down there is
yeah that was all a trick that was just
a freakin trick I wouldn't even know how
you would get over there in the first
place I did yes so I got some extra
Mario's back so this is boating well for
me it didn't bode well for me for a long
time you guys were already giving up on
me saying that I was gonna be nary a
chance that anything was gonna go bad
but that's one level down and I only got
97 I don't know why I did this but
that's my celebratory move don't you
guys know about that my favorite thing
to do after I win anyway missed me
missed missed big dick missed me
so what do we got going on here this one
if if anything goes wrong in this one
it's gonna take a long time to get back
to but that's why I'm a freaking badass
and I know exactly I'm gonna save this I
don't know when this is gonna be needed
ah
why why why can't I hit these oh god oh
god oh god
well Giersch okay everything's fine I
still got the POW I don't know why I got
the power I need to go down there don't
get to me oh I kiss just got down here
that would have been easy maybe that
would have just been a mush
I wouldn't again what I mean that's all
don't you dare I like how all the
goombas are just wah
Frick I like how the goombas are just
walking off and do their own amazed
they're so stupid who would fall off a
ledge that's right in front of them what
kind of [ __ ] would do that someone
who's obviously bad at games and name
rhymes with FARC applier fart Farkas and
ire
something like that I don't know okay I
still don't know why I have this pal I'm
assuming that it's gonna be useful at
some point and I'm assuming that I need
to jump on these which I do not like
okay how much more do I need to jump on
that first try baby I can do this but
then when it comes to the super expert
levels I'm not gonna be able to do it
alright I'm not gonna be I was so close
to the world record maybe if I could
just skedaddle de little more but that's
two down that's two down
two down so it's good it's good I feel
like my I feel like I'm panicking a bit
more than I need to but these are these
are tough
I can't spin jump anymore yeah so long
as I can get some more one ups to
because I made the last one with no
things but I didn't what up at the end
of the level
I was probably supposed to go up that
was nice
I'm the best oh I can go up higher nice
got it
Wow I'll take it just in case something
goes bad thank you up here no I guess
I'm supposed to just keep going up Oh
perfect thank you are you gonna shoot
one well that right
Oh over here I don't like you in my
neighborhood so I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to go oh why why why he's
not gonna skedaddle out of my
neighborhood anymore piss balls okay so
that's dangerous looking yeah I know I
know that's what I need I know I know
yeah okay so there's good enough I don't
know how I'm gonna be able to get these
things that they want me to get oh I'll
take that
boink boink
grandpa try that once more come on give
me some good link there we go hey wait
no no no does this mean oh hey come back
here I needed that why did he go away
why did he have to go away maybe I can
wink on your head yes okay God that
we're down here this is a big maze but
complicated it's not a problem because I
know what I need to do no I don't know
what I need to do there holy [ __ ] that
was scary do I bounce on them can i
bounce on ghosts with a boot I don't
trust that oh god everything is gonna be
fine because I'm gonna go the other way
because obviously I'm not supposed to go
the way of the ghosts it's a big lying
lying pants and there's got to be
another path over here well I was wrong
but I believe that now I should be able
to get a big one I can't climb those so
no I can't
I've screwed myself I have a faithfully
screwed myself over to the point where I
can't even get back up the god Frick
squirt Frankie so there's got to be some
puzzle with the goose that shows where
I'm supposed to let me let me figure out
where this goes first
he's probably gonna lead to nothing
isn't only
Oh God Oh No there was something there
was something over there there was there
was something over there okay so that
that's good to know it was something
over there I don't know if I can reach
it with this one but they're definitely
world ooh never mind crap crap sickle
what a bunch of baloney fine
so there's got to be something with
those ghosts right it's gotta be no
notes nope what are you supposed to do
Wow so I'm gonna go all the way back I'm
gonna go on top of things but just take
some of that I'm gonna figure out a way
to get up here no that's not what I need
you I mean I would like
I mean I could get another fire flower
that would be delightful
nice
now
can I leave this Putin
okay so there was a way to get up there
there was away so this oh oh it's the
party room yeah okay good thank you you
probably don't even know that I'm
playing the hundred Mario challenge and
that was very
duh I can bounce on the thing before
when I have the balloon ride it up and
then I have the boot on the way out
duh it makes so much sense now it makes
so much sense
damn it I should have realized it even I
got this thank you for the nice ride sir
you're welcome in my neighborhood okay
so now that I got this okay how fast do
I need to go here Oh God
are they still wait what oh god damn it
what I can hit you know is it this one
a tad a heated booth yeah check boy baby
I didn't need anything that I was doing
before and now I'm gonna blast through
this because I am the man with the plan
okay that's a little odd not sure what -
not sure how to feel about that one this
has all kinds of bizarre slightly
arousing oh wait that's the end of the
stage there was no point to this there
was no point to this
ah no god damn it wasn't a secret it was
the only way to go I'm a I need to
abandon this shouldn't have been going
on it in the further there we go we got
this okay so that is the first episode
of the expert levels in the hundred
mario challenge I still got 90 left I
got 90 left and I took way too long in
that level but it's okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to more expert levels coming at
you real soon and as always I will see
my saw something in the dark